for a heart plus two-thirds we're gonna
add these fractions Adams okay but
they're not in a very good cool but
adding right now are they why not anyone
yet yeah yeah very good they're not
talking the same language are they okay
so therefore and you can see what
Maria's done she's put them on the
center nominee rb6 y is 6 a good number
16 good sir renault sure yeah very good
the what we're looking for is the phrase
rod is lowest common multiple you can do
/ 12 / 24 those it all work but six is
better because it's smaller it's easier
to deal with so what's a half if you
make the denominator six well write this
as whatever white is equal to our half
yeah yeah Nick not yet drunk 3636 very
good and two-thirds what do i do the top
one Gabrielle 46 there we go okay so
when you put this together now they talk
at the same language now I can just add
the numerators and you can see Livi
intermixing or less kind of nice and
neat not required but it's nice what do
we do to this thing to get x equals
negative 30 there's one thing we need to
do to both sides yeah yeah we want to
take away it up like other girls I want
to talk about number that leaves just
the X by itself and the number i heard
was take away five take away five yeah
i'm the reason that's great is because
it gets rid of all of this all in one
hit they do that now this one let's see
what's going on here okay because I can
see what's happened this is actually a
very I would be very very unsurprised if
a lot of us have put that it's a very
easy mistake to make let me go through
what I think maybe the thought process
was okay um there's a one here I don't
want that one to be there so I'm going
to take one away from both sides I'll
take one away from inside now that it's
more on the left please move that 17
take point one it's six so you can see
where i get x equals 24 right i divide
both sides by
three so what's up what's what's gone
wrong what did I do that was on
problematic about the way I approached
it anyone else who wants a offer I'm
suggest Brad your shot okay so i'm
subtracting one yeah but why is it a
problem I think you're right but why
can't I take away one from both sides
because I want not to be there anymore
so what can I remove it Christian we
think if you take away one from both
sides in x 3 x minus 2 very good so
because there's subtraction your way
which is not your same brand when you
subtract one again it becomes an even
bigger subtraction if we take away to
right so in fact I don't want too long
this is wrong I don't want to subtract 1
from both sides what should I actually
do to both sides together yourself you
don't want to suggest the any he'll have
one very good i want to do the opposite
of what i was there ok so if i add one
here and add one here that will leave
you with 3x what's on the right hand
side 8 so therefore I will shred you now
to get to the my final online yeah John
friend not saying an improper fraction
that's fine if you wanted to change it
into a mixed new robot would it be a 23
ok so you could write to route 66 oh no
no no no not that's fine but you have to
write a lot of success to go on forever
and you did different number of them it
might be easier just to say that a is 6
plus 2 right yeah so six thirds is too
and then there are two thirds left over
and there's your mix theorem ok all
right last one force actually sutra is
exactly right just in case you couldn't
quite see them if you are drew a diagram
it was really easy to see I games are
awesome they don't have to be beautiful
but you know what the hair picture says
a thousand words right the easiest axis
of symmetry is there right down the
middle you can see Christians drawing
one across the one that's the ones that
are
yes are the diagonals right here all the
way through if you turn your head can
you turn your head with me 45 degrees to
the left or right you'll see either of
them and you can see you can reflect a
cross and get the same shape right by
the way that's something the square can
do but do you notice the rectangle can't
do that how many accidents ooh [ __ ] is a
rectangular it's only got two at first 2
that we mentioned because look if I try
leave my try again turn your head with
me do you see you wouldn't get the shape
you wouldn't get it when you reflect it
across for example fire fly through
cross this bit I get a shape that looks
more like this do you see that you see
the reflection and it's the same the
other way so you don't get a symmetric
Roche